the i-team first with news of a proposal  in washington that could have big  benefits for las vegas  senator catherine cortez masto and  congressman stephen horsford  have submitted a plan to incentivize the  hospitality industry  to re-hire workers and bring convention  business back so  how do they do that well companies would  get a tax credit for rehiring  and then travelers would get a credit on  all their trade show related expenses to  come here  our first order of business of course is  crushing this virus and we are making  great progress in doing that  and as we defeat this virus we need to  quickly be able to rebound  and this bill will help us do that now  the proposal also includes a credit for  restaurants who say renovated or  increased service post pandemic  if it passes all of these measures would  be in place for several  years